Linux Slammer is a 31 year old woman
with a rare hormonal disorder called
hypopituitarism that gives her the
appearance of a 10 year old child she
also has a dumb name and that probably
makes her feel bad she lives in the sarn
mental institution in Estonia and is
regarded as their most dangerous patient
in 2007 an art therapy instructor named
Anna takes up the therapist Post in The
Institute Anna is informed of Lena by a
doctor and also of the security
procedures as they are talking a fellow
doctor runs up to them and informs them
that Lena is missing in no time the
whole facility goes into lockdown and
the doctor places Anna in a dark room
assuring her that it is safe before
leaving however Anna is not alone in the
room and a child sitting behind her is
drawing a picture of her Anna asks her
name and lo and behold it is the
psychopath Lena the childlike woman
holds a sharp pencil in her hand ready
to kill Anna but before she can do so
luckily the guards in the doctor arrive
and take her away some days pass spy and
Lena orchestrates an escape from The
sarn Institute she lures a guard into
her cell by seducing him and then talks
with him for a while when the guard is
distracted she suddenly grabs him and
bashes his head against the wall killing
him serves him right for being seduced
by a 10 year old then she sneaks her way
out of the facility with the help of her
psychotic friend editi editi takes down
one of the guards standing near the
front entrance in exchange for a piece
of candy it turns out that Lena had
already planned everything revealing
that she is not only dangerous but also
a genius she is tracked in his movements
in the facility and knows the exact time
she departs shortly after she approaches
Anna and pretends to run off into the
woods so that Anna will leave her car
unattended and run into the facility to
inform the doctors the plan works and
when no one is around Lena sneaks into
the trunk of Anna's car and remains
hidden inside the facility Anna informs
the doctor about what she just saw and
the latter reassures her that the
situation will be handled by the police
Anna then returns home without real
advising that Lena is hiding inside her
trunk when she arrives home the little
psychopath also follows her inside there
Lena greets Anna with a crowbar to the
Head knocking her out afterwards Lena
goes up to Anna's study and uses her
computer she looks up missing American
girls and finds one that she Bears
resemblance to it is about a girl named
Esther Albright who went missing in 2003
confident Lena dresses up in Anna's
clothes and as she is about to leave she
realizes that Anna has woken up the poor
woman begs for Mercy but Lena picks up
the Crowbar and bludgeons her to death
later at night the crazy girl heads to a
park and pretends as though she is lost
soon an Estonian police officer
approaches her and inquires if she is
okay Lena introduces herself as Esther
Albright and claims that her parents are
in the United States the scene then cuts
to Darien Connecticut where wealthy
artist Alan Albright and his
philanthropist wife Trisha are attending
their son Gunners fencing tournament the
couple leave the venue after their son
wins the match and it soon becomes
obvious that Allen has still not come to
terms with The Disappearance of his
daughter Esther before they get in the
car to head home they are approached by
detective Donnan who is in charge of the
police search for Esther Donnan informs
Alan and treasure that their daughter
has been found in Estonia much to their
shock and frankly disbelief the very
next day Trisha travels to Estonia and
meets Esther after four long years she
is extremely happy to have her daughter
back and hugs her tightly after the two
reach the states the family has an
emotional reunion at the airport however
for some reason Gunner seems
unenthusiastic about meeting his sister
shortly after Trisha brings the Imposter
girl home and immediately starts having
doubts when she notices that Esther has
forgotten about the death of her
grandmother and also because the girl
can now draw exceptionally well the
following day Trisha takes her to the
family psychologist Dr Seeger to gain
information on her life during her
supposed kidnapping in Estonia after the
session Esther is sent outside the
office and the doctor calls in Trisha as
the little psychopath eavesdrops on
their conversation Dr Seeger says that
all of Esther's answers were wrong for
example she mistakenly called Dr
Seeger's parrot the wrong name even
though Esther had known it previously if
you want to piss your doctor off just
forget the name of their pet bird
hearing this as their fakes a fall to
intervene in their discussion she also
pretends to get injured prompting Trisha
to leave with her abruptly as the two
are heading home Esther notices a man
clicking pictures of her he turns out to
be none other than the detective Donna
this worries us there and she starts
fearing that the detective may find out
about her soon after a while they get
home and Alan begins bonding with Esther
over their shared love of painting which
never interested the real Esther
meanwhile Trisha observes that Esther's
apparent return has changed her husband
for the better as he is now more
inspired with his artwork and more
affectionate towards his family the same
night as the family is having dinner
detective Donna interrupts them he
welcomes us their back but seems
suspicious of her noticing this Esther
leaves the dinner table and eavesdrops
on the Family's conversation with the
detect Donnan suggests the family have a
counseling session with Dr Seeger to get
a better understanding of their daughter
during her disappearance Esther who has
been hearing all of this gets worried
that she might get caught so she goes
back to the dinner table and changes the
topic right away hey have I told you
guys that I'm like 30 years old later at
night she plots to run away thinking
that Donna is on to her but reconsiders
when she gets the idea that she can
seduce Alan into a romantic relationship
oh God in the next scene Trisha and Alan
are getting ready to attend a party as
they get romantic inside their room ask
their spies on them and rips Trish's
dress out of jealousy afterwards the
couple leaves as they're home alone with
her brother Gunner but instead of
spending time with his little sister
Gunner organizes a backyard party and
invites several friends Esther also
joins the party and when Gunner behaves
bluntly towards her she responds by
talking back to him rudely suddenly
detective Donna arrives at the Albright
home Gunner answers the door and
requests that he leave as he's trying to
have a party however Donna insists on
using the bathroom when Gunner agrees he
enters Esther's room and starts
searching through it he even steals a
vinyl record from there which has
Alina's fingerprints on it as he is
leaving Esther finds out that he has
taken the record from her room and
decides to follow him meanwhile Allen
and Trisha return home the latter calls
Esther but gets no response so she heads
to her room before tailing Donna Esther
had turned on the shower to make it seem
like she was in the bathroom assuming
that Esther is taking a shower Trisha
takes the opportunity to search through
a Keepsake Bible that the little girl
brought with her from Estonia to her
surprise Tricia finds defaced family
photos of her and Alan an address for
detective Donna and a stamp identifying
The sarn Institute back at donnen's
place he verifies that the fingerprint
lifted from the record does not match
Esther's suddenly he feels a weird
presence as if someone is lurking in the
shadows and when he turns around Esther
starts stabbing him repeatedly but as
she is about to finish the detective off
Trisha appears out of the blue but
instead of helping the detective she
shoots him dead he here it is revealed
that Trisha knew all along that Lena is
not her daughter she also confesses that
Gunner accidentally killed the real
Esther during an argument four years
earlier and she covered it up without
Alan's knowledge as she knew it would
affect him the most following this she
interrogates us there and finds that she
is a murderous psychopath who escaped a
psychiatric facility since she could
have robbed them and disappeared Trisha
speculates that Lena has a larger scheme
in mind possibly one that involves
killing her whole family however since
Esther's return has ignited a spark in
her husband Trisha wants to keep things
going so through a mutually beneficial
Arrangement where they both have
something to lose Trisha compels Lena to
continue her ruse and keep quiet I told
a little white lie to my family but you
might kill my whole family yeah we're
about even here afterwards the two throw
Donna's body done the same well or
Trisha disposed of the real Esther four
years ago after returning home Trisha
privately tells Gunner what is really
going on and he too agrees to go along
with the plan over the course of the few
weeks Trisha coaches Lena on how to fool
Dr Seeger as well as family friends to
convince everyone that she is the real
Esther however the little brat could
care less and refuses to be bossed
around eventually Trisha gets fed up
with her Antics and decides to kill Lena
by feeding her a poisoned pasta but the
plan hits a roadblock when Lena learns
that Alan is going on a business trip
without her prompting her to throw a
tantrum and leave the dinner table
without eating later Lena gives the food
to a rat that lives in a room and a few
days later finds that the rodent has
died with this she quickly deduces that
it is Trisha's work or maybe that Trisha
is a [ __ ] cook and decides to take
revenge the next day Lena retaliates by
tricking Trisha into sipping on a
smoothie containing the dead mouse as
days pass by Lena and Alan spend more
time with each other so her infatuation
towards him grows even more one day
Trisha Gunner and Alina go to a train
station to see Alan off on a business
trip there Lena attempts to kill Trisha
and her son by pushing them in front of
a moving train but luckily her plan is
foiled when she is interrupted by a
passing commuter as soon as Trisha
realizes this they leave the station
with the intent of killing Lena once and
for all Lena pepper sprays Gunner
hijacks Trisha's car and flees she then
plays a song and smokes a cigarette
whilst in the car little did she know
that Trisha has called the cops on her
and that they are already on her tail in
no time she gets pulled over by a cop
who forces her to return home now Trisha
and Gunner are hell-bent on killing Lena
as at this point she has become too much
of a nuisance to have around Trisha
plans on slitting Lena's wrists and
making her death look like
self-destruction caused by the trauma
she experienced during the years she was
missing shortly after she leaves Gunner
to take care of Lena thinking that he
can handle her however things don't
quite go according to plan as the crazy
girl breaks free from Gunner and ends up
murdering him with his own fencing sword
on guard [ __ ] in the meantime Trisha
gets distracted by Alan who calls her to
inform her that he is returning home as
he also got a call from the police about
Esther's fleeing attempt then she
returns to check in on Gunner only to
find him being repeatedly stabbed by
Lena the scene devastates Trisha and in
a fit of rage she gets into a brutal
fight with Lena she slams the girl all
over the kitchen and even manages to
slash her a few times with a knife
however during the scuffle the two
inadvertently ignite a fire in the gas
burner the fight shifts away from the
kitchen but the burner is left to light
and in no time the house catches on fire
this is still not enough to stop the
fight as the two reach the rooftop
adamant on killing one another at the
same time Allen returns home to see the
horrific scene of his house going up in
Flames while a vicious fight between the
two women ensues on the mansion's roof
during their brawl both Lena and Trisha
lose their balance and end up hanging on
the edge of the House Allen rushes up to
help his supposed daughter and his wife
however both of them start yelling at
him to save them first but before Alan
can make sense of the situation Trisha
loses her grip and Falls to her death
devastated Alan pulls Lena up and
Embraces her but just then he notices
the girl's fake teeth and finally
realizes that she is an imposter he then
calls her a monster but this only
infuriates Lena prompting her to push
him off the roof sadly Alan meets the
same fate as his wife shortly after as
the fire trucks arrive Lena goes into
the burning house where she removes her
bloodied ribbons and puts on fresh ones
to deflect any suspicion about her in
front of the fireman she then comes out
of the house in the final scene Dr
Seeger meets Lena and puts her up for
adoption the movie ends as The Psychotic
girl gives out a menacing smile implying
that she is about to continue her reign
of terror with a new family soon
subscribe for more videos like this turn
on notifications and leave a like to
help the channel out thank you for
watching